hey everybody welcome to live covering
with Jesse and today we're gonna keep
working on our homepage so I just
finished turning that card that we had
made on Friday was it Friday yeah anyway
so I just finished turning that card
into a component so that's what you can
see on the screen here probably can't
see it right now it's fonts not big
enough but make the font a bit bigger we
could see that we have this profile card
now and so we've replaced a lot of the
code with this profile card now this
still is a lot but once we put this data
into a different format may be imported
and you know then it wouldn't really be
that much and at some point I would
imagine this data would be populated
from
graph QL but for right now we're gonna
hard code this and
just so we can get things ready for my
presentation first presentation is
Thursday yeah Thursday so over the next
two weeks I'm going to be presenting
this website to a lot of different
people here at the university that I
work for so I need to get that ready and
the launch date potentially is now
pushed back a little bit I still would
like to launch it on time which would be
by the end of the month
but having to present to all these
people is really gonna slow that down so
I'm still shooting for them but
realistically it may be later we'll see
I did have a question here Michael said
I thought Jesse tweeted he was sick and
wasn't going today I tweeted that
yesterday so I was sick over the weekend
but I'm feeling feel better today
and let's see hey Anna how's it going
and hey everybody in the in the live
chat so I'm gonna start out let me give
you the link to start with so you all
can see this the link to the repository
with the code is in the description to
this video and now you can actually see
the site as we're working at on it with
that end Rock link so end Rock if you
haven't used it before heard about it
and Rock is an awesome little tool and
it lets it lets you share a site that
you're working on locally with anybody
online who you give the link to so it
really helps us here on the stream and
we were given full access to an
unlimited amount of users using the link
at one time which is really awesome so
check out and Rock if you get a chance
I've found it to be very useful and I'm
probably gonna use it for maybe one of
these meetings okay alright so first
thing we need to do then is let's commit
what I've done and push that to the repo
so you all can see that and then we can
move on so let me commit that first and
then I see a few more questions in the
live chat that would be good to address
first before we start any coding so let
me commit and then all I'll answer the
questions all rights to get status oops
can't spell there we are
yes can I steal my spell oh no that one
worked let me know if the fonts too
small as well I can never tell from my
screen if it's too small
not okay so pages and profile
yep that's exactly what what I expected
to change which is good so let's do get
add and we're gonna add that little dot
afterwards just means we're gonna add
everything and then go do yarn cm this
is something we have set up for our
project in particular you wouldn't
normally do this unless you you've set
up your project this way but if you do
want to contribute to this project when
you go to commit type yarn cm instead of
a normal git commit and then you'll
you'll have these options to be able to
more properly format your commit so
let's add victim
I guess web teacher can phone no
breaking changes I so this needs to whoa
oops I guess I forgot to remove some of
this which is a common mistake at least
for me so let's try this what's the
command it sneaky watching right now
Nikki told me about a command I could
use to not have to type this all in
again and now I can't remember what it
was what was it
let's just try
see and can I get no retry that's it the
retry flag thank you our shed said two
dashes yeah
and thank sneaky that's so much nicer
than having to type it all again all
right awesome
so we'll get push and now that's
available on github so y'all can check
out how we pulled out what we had done
last week and now it's its own component
and all the styles of course are in this
component as well so we were able to
remove some styles from this main index
file let's see oh there was an error it
didn't catch that let's see
oh okay to reoffer the link profile link
that's fun
Oh 58
that's odd that the committe went
through even though we had an error I
thought it wouldn't get through so why a
nun props file a same and lank at
profile card 58 we should not have a
class name unless somehow this is being
passed down because it's in card actions
ok harsh it said it's not air just a
warning
okay if I have to guess with that error
or warning is about I'm gonna say
potentially since we have this link
inside the card actions something's
going on with this yeah that's that's
what I'm guessing that material UI is
attaching something in here in
particular class name because we're not
obviously we're not trying to put class
name on the link component so with
scarred actions okay yeah so for now I
guess I can live with that warning let
me double check yeah everything's
displaying properly so I'm gonna live
with that warning for now I would like
to sort that out at some point before we
launch but I need to get this looking
good so I can't really get sidetracked
by that right now because running out of
time to update the look here and
speaking of the look let me pull this
over for those of you who for whatever
reason can't get on and rock you know
this is how we're looking now let me
make it smaller since we're primarily
looking at the the mobile view this is
that component that we had made I asked
my boss about the italic which is what
we had gone over last week and he said
he preferred this instead of the italic
but he would like some type of like icon
that's quotation mark or potentially
even like a watermark thing behind this
you know that's a quotation mark so
probably put that in that's not really a
priority right now if anyone wants to
you know try to see how that would look
you know feel free to open a pull
request we'll check it out
but I'm not going to spend any more time
on this component right now what I can
do and I probably won't do this on the
stream when we wanted a different
component but now that we have this
component we can put in what we want I'm
going to add you know a faculty profile
and alumni profile and throw in some
different content and I'll be able to
use that to display the homepage at my
meetings all right so now let's work on
let's work on this events I know this is
an important section to my boss the
events and then the news which did we
even make that you know we didn't so
let's start out with this events one and
work on it in particular we're
definitely going to want I think the
images need to be a bit bigger that's at
least for me this is really hard to see
something that small it would work maybe
if our events were just maybe somebody's
face and it took up most of their you
know the area but that's not how the
events are going to be and also needs
some sort of description I would think
since we're talking about events here it
might not be a bad idea to put a date
now eventually we're probably going to
want to connect this with some type of I
don't know event service so maybe
Eventbrite maybe just a Google Calendar
I don't know so the data for these
events is not going to come from our
WordPress CMS it's probably gonna come
from somewhere else we don't need to
worry about that right now for the
presentation we'll just hard code some
stuff
all right I did say I wanted to address
one of these questions in here before we
coated
why was it
okay Alexander asked do you have any
projects that we can work on with you
yep pretty much any of the projects that
are in the fu s Markham github
organization which you can get the link
to this project here and then from there
you can easily get to the organization
and see our other projects but pretty
much any of those projects you can work
on check out the issues for each project
and that'll give you some ideas on what
still needs done or if you notice
something that really looks broken you
could bring up an issue or open a pull
request and you know potentially you
know that could get merged then pretty
much every pull requests for the most
part does get merged in occasionally it
will need some work before it it's ready
to be merged in but I try to work with
everybody so if you're nervous about you
know submitting pull requests to
projects these projects that we work on
for the stream are a great place to
start because I'll help you out as much
as I can to work on your pool request
alright so let me get started we're
gonna use this Pomodoro timer you go for
25 minutes I do need to make sure the
stream we can go maybe like an hour 15
minutes
total with this stream so I have some
other stuff I have to go somewhere a
little bit later and then after that I
have a meeting with my boss so the
afternoon is going to be very full
all right so let's check out this
component so we're going to be in the
index dot JSP in the pages folder so in
the pages folder index and I'm gonna
shut this because will mostly be working
in here first so what we'll do is we'll
we'll edit it directly in here get it
looking like we want it to look and then
maybe later on probably not on the
stream maybe on the stream you'll see
we'll turn it into its own component and
make sure that it's customizable enough
that we could use it for multiple things
all right so right now we're using this
built-in you know lists that is part of
material UI we could keep using it
oh sorry
so let's yeah let's kind of see how what
the limits are of this component and see
if we can work with this to make it look
the way we want it to look and if not
then we could you know try to build
something else so let's go back and just
work within dev tools for a few minutes
so let me adjust this a bit okay we're
up here so the first thing I'd like to
adjust then is this image yeah so this
container for the image currently is the
images are 40 by 40 and that's a bit too
small let's see if we can go 60 you see
how that looks
whoops
okay a bit bigger not too bad
you know also I want to I want to check
this out on my phone so we really want
this to look good on a phone if you need
to I'm gonna be constantly kind of going
back to my phone so if you can check
this out check out that n drop link on a
phone that would be ideal and I'm just
gonna copy this and send it to myself so
that I don't have to type it up on my
phone
it's
okay so now I can see this on my phone
and obviously the changes I just made
aren't gonna be visible on my phone
because I just didn't dev tools but this
gives me an idea of what those images
look like on the phone and they do look
way too small even on a phone let me
know if you're getting a lot of weird
noise from my phone being close to my
mic if you are all try to do a better
job of holding my phone farther away
Michael is asking why not use the
responsive mode and dev tools
I do use the responsive mode sometimes
but it just doesn't look the same as as
a phone right and and to get that that
real feeling of like the scroll and
touching and stuff it it just doesn't
give the same feedback so I like to
actually look at it on my phone too
you can also I mean it doesn't have to
be an Grogg so you know potentially I
could do this yet application no that's
not it I can't remember where I guess
I'm not gonna do it because I can't
remember where to go I gotta set it up
is it Network No
I don't remember at all where to go to
set this up did you remember where to go
to to use a phone with dev tools
open localhost 4040 all right let me
check this out oh cool thanks are [ __ ] I
didn't realize that you could get a nice
UI like this with end rot that's pretty
cool so I can see all the requests that
are going through right now awesome
anyway the 3w you used to be able to do
there we are remote devices
yeah that's have been uses throw up for
a while so couldn't remember how I used
to use this okay so that's for forward
so 3088 alright cool that works so I
should be able to go then too
so for you or you can use Angra of
course but for me since my phone is
directly connected here I should be able
to just go to ports while local hosts
8080 and I can see the the site here so
I can't actually see it and the
advantage of doing it this way is that
changes I make in dev tools will show up
automatically on on my phone so anyway
just for those of you who want to do
something like that when when you're
developing then you can plug in your
phone need to enable that
so enable remote debugging which you can
there documentation linked here and dev
tools but so you go up here to your
little menu and then go to more tools
and remote devices there's a lot more
tools here now than I remember there
being the last time I checked this maybe
I need to read those release notes more
those there's what's new things here
I always just skip over them because I'm
usually in the middle of something okay
anyway so I still think this is too
small
actually
that's weird I thought I would
automatically reflect changes on my
phone but I guess it's not
that's really weird
hmm
oh you know what I gotta open up another
inspector that's why okay so here's the
inspector that I can I need to change
for my phone so maybe I won't do it like
this because only I'll be able to see
the changes right now unless I I guess
unless I show my screen which I don't
really want to go through all that right
now okay so I'm just gonna stick with n
grog on my phone so it'll be the same as
as you all have anyway which might be
better for the stream so if I was
developing by myself and not doing a
stream then I do recommend using dev
tools and opening up that second dev
tools window and then you can see the
changes live you know right there in
your phone it's a lot faster for now I'm
just gonna do some changes here and
since I'm not here we go see we'll
switch over to this mode yeah let's just
pick a phone iPhone 4 okay so we'll
switch over here so it's kind of you
know simulating a mobile device and then
once we get some values that look like
they'll work then we'll actually put
them in to the react component and when
I save then it'll update an end grukk so
then we can all see it on our phones
oh let's see how its set I should got
timed out by the but it's funny I guess
we have a bot now that stops people from
spamming kapps so are all of our shits
messages got deleted
oh no oh whoa okay so watch out for that
now everyone I suppose we have a button
here now that might have been put in so
since we're doing that 24 hours a day
music stream I guess that was probably
put in to stop people from spamming and
in that channel so or on that stream I'm
assuming so anyway so note no caps okay
so this is a little bit bigger this
might be too big yeah that's too big
let's drop it down then let's go to 80
I will try 80 and go over here I think
all right list item is the class that we
use let's go up here to our list item if
you're not familiar with react there are
lots of different ways to do styles this
is one of the ways so we have a
JavaScript object and we're putting our
Styles inside that object so it's very
similar to CSS but you can see the
format is that of an object and not you
know your normal CSS format so where's
my list item
did I read that wrong the class is list
item that's odd
so we have that class but I'm not seeing
it up here
that is what I want right listen that's
our or would it be a versa maybe we need
that on the avatar
do we have styles coming in here no
we're not adding any additional CSS so
let's try to put a clasp right here on
this have it's our last name and let's
just call it avatar
well you know what it looks like we're
already adding some classes somewhere
else let's find it there we are okay so
we can put class names right there on
the avatar alright so that should work
then so let's go ahead and put it on a
few more of these so I'm not worried
about the formatting we have Auto format
unsaved here so we should be fine after
so I'm using that class that CSS class
here as the key and then the value is
going to be an object that has key value
pairs and the key value pairs are going
to reflect what we normally do and in
CSS so in this case we're just going to
do with height and so I'm gonna copy
this to save time and you can see we've
already done some things with great
points here we may end up doing that
again but for now I'm just worried about
the mobile view so let's take this down
to 80 and save it
oops forgot a comma area and they don't
like that comma there okay oops I
thought I fixed that great
for fresh area just didn't refresh
automatically okay that looks alright I
want to pull some data from actual
events that we have so I'm just I'm
gonna move this over on the other screen
so I don't have to keep flipping back
and forth and I'm gonna grab some some
events that we actually have going on
right now
so let's go back here and put in Class A
in this front one where we have our
primary text I'm going to say in crisis
American higher education and put in
these are the actual events that are
appearing on the home page of the
website right now
all right so
oh yeah
okay so let's see how this looks with
actual titles okay not too bad this
definitely needs to be larger I mean the
font size needs to be larger this is too
small especially if these are the titles
so I'm gonna just hard code some fonts
in here just to see what we want
let's try 16 pixels which I guess is a
default anyway 16 mm I wonder
I really don't like the way this looks
with the titles on a small screen here
now I mean this is a very narrow phone
most phones aren't going to be this
narrow but still maybe maybe at some
point when the screen so small we just
don't include the images at all for
events or we will have to come up with
some other thing because I don't want to
go very much smaller for these images it
it'll be very hard to even see anything
the other alternative is if for events
let's say we don't use images at all but
instead we we have a date actually the
main site right now does not use images
for the events they just have a little
date icon maybe we should maybe we
should do that we could potentially make
the component so that if an image is
passed to it then we do display an image
otherwise it doesn't display the image
so we'll still have a lot of flexibility
and be able to reuse this component but
in the case of events we'll be able to
show more info how does that sound
let me check my time all right about
three minutes I want to see what
feedback you all have about what I just
explained
and I am checking this out on my phone
it doesn't look that bad on my phone and
this is still with the smaller font size
but the IMP
the size the font size for the title is
just so much smaller than the image is
it it doesn't go together so we we
definitely won't have any bigger images
we need have a bigger font size and that
just won't allow us to have very long
titles without it looking weird so let
me read off some of the suggestions here
that some of your thoughts on this Nicki
says what about a background image with
text on top yeah we could think about
that you know what this might be a
really good time to check out how things
like this are done in a material UI and
other circumstances so maybe we'll take
a look then not right now because we got
a break coming up so I'll take
five-minute break we'll go to the lab
chat answer some questions and then when
we come back maybe we'll take five
minutes or so we'll look at the material
design documentation and just see how
they do lists and get some examples
hopefully maybe we get some examples
even of you know kind of news or events
yeah there's probably some examples like
that in the material design
documentation already
how Peter says do people even still have
iPhone 4s I don't really know that was
just the first thing on the list so I
clicked hit but I mean it I think it's
better to so this is I believe the
narrowest tongue you can have is 320
pixels so it's good to look at it there
because if it looks if we can get it to
look okay there it's probably still
gonna look okay on a slightly larger
phone okay all right so let me I'm gonna
go ahead and just take the break now or
start the timer for the break now I'm
going to scroll up to the top and get
through as many questions and comments
as I can so if you have a question or
comment please put it in the live chat
now
okay John Hanson said I'd like to see
the border on the quote to be a bit more
transparent she was talking about this
quote yeah we could try a little bit
more transparent at this point though I
I'm gonna try to resist the temptation
to make small changes like that just
because of time so I'm gonna try to like
put off of those changes for for later
for after I have some of these
presentations because if I can get right
now if I get a few components to be
exactly how I want it like a hundred
percent done and I go to present it it's
gonna look like it's not finished but if
I get all the components let's say 90
percent finished it's going to look like
it's finished you most people won't even
worry about details
let's see Anna says this typing speed
matter for coding
Harshit says absolutely but tools like
smart code editors help says code is all
about typing logical stuff uh yeah I
would I would add as well do you this
typing speed matter I would say it's a
little bit different so if you go to
take a normal typing test for typing
speed I think it's different than what a
coder would type so the reason the
reason is different is so normally as a
coder you're hitting different keys than
most people would hit right we don't do
a lot of data entry we're entering you
know long strings of text right we're
grabbing data from api's and things all
right so the keys that we hit are in odd
places on the keyboard not only that but
we do have a lot of help from editors
right so we just need to type in the
first few letters or something and then
we hit tab and we're good to go
so traditional typing speed I don't
think is that important for coding so
you know traditionally you have a
paragraph you see how fast you can type
the paragraph or something like that and
it's all just you know normal words the
only odd characters you would have or if
there's a quotation mark question mark
exclamation point period okay it's not
not really a big deal but when coding
it's it's almost reverse is you're using
mostly special characters and very
little you know strings of like normal
words so I would say what could make up
for if you're a slow typer what could
definitely make up for it make it even
faster than a fast typer encoding is if
you get if you're very knowledgeable
about all the keyboard shortcuts that
you can use with your particular editor
so if you are good with something let's
say like Emmett which allows you to
write your large amounts of HTML very
quickly with just a few keystrokes
then you could definitely you know code
faster than somebody who may be a fast
typer but doesn't take advantage of any
shortcuts like that so my answer to that
question of does typing speed matter for
coding is maybe it depends it depends on
on what you're doing and what would you
take advantage of in terms of what
editors can do so actually there was a
question about this somewhere I can't
remember where it was it was somewhere
online there was a very similar question
and someone was being kind of rude about
the about it was it on I think was on
the free code camp forum so there was
one response on the forum that was I
think kind of really made it seem like
speed was very very important and I
didn't I didn't agree so anyway but
that's my opinion on the subject of of
typing
let me see okay my timer is up and I got
through most of the questions
okay there are a few follow-up comments
I think with the the speed thing
okay so Nikki says I hate my as AZERTY
keyboard as opposed to the QWERTY
keyboard so that's the the arrangement
of the keys saying the special
characters are not visible on my
keyboard I said doesn't help I never
realized that in assists thanks to the
answer you're welcome and a no problem
all right
there's Ennis had one more follow-up
question what are the top skills needed
to get a front-end developer role HTML
CSS JavaScript yeah you're gonna need
that no matter what as a front-end
developer and then depending on the job
you might need to know a framework so a
framework or library right so maybe the
job you want they work with angular it
would be good if you knew some angular
same thing for react or ember or view or
just jQuery so but you can't go wrong
with being good with just regular
JavaScript HTML CSS for sure now in
terms of like other skills definitely
need to be able to write reliable code
being able to write tests is a big plus
as well
Harshit I know I don't write tests very
much at all so before you say anything I
realized that I'm not the best at this
but I recognize it's important I'm
trying to change right but that's a big
thing and being able to teach yourself
new things quickly is very very
important I would much rather hire
somebody as a developer who can
demonstrate to me that they've been able
to pick up new things and produce like
production-ready code quickly then
somebody who happens to be an expert
right now but it's they're very
resistant to change and don't like to
learn new things
right because everything's always going
to change if they're an expert at
whatever the big thing is right now it
doesn't mean that they're going to be an
expert at whatever the big thing is
tomorrow so anyway that's what I would
look for if I'm hiring a developer the
in terms of their code you know you can
prove that you know what you're doing
that's from your projects right from
what you have and get up it's a little
bit harder to prove the other things
about being able to learn quickly I mean
there are some ways to do it right I
actually like to see on a developer's
github profile that they're doing
tutorial courses as well so I like to
see a mix of real projects for clients
or at least like side projects that
they're doing and then tutorial stuff
even if they don't want to put it on the
github I'd still like to see it on the
resume and then if I can see like they
did this boot camp let's say to learn
react and then I look I've looked at the
dates and said okay well like they
graduated from this boot camp and then
pretty much immediately had this
production ready react that going to me
that signals while they learned enough
in that short amount of time to be able
to build that that's impressive
so there are some ways from the side of
someone who's hiring that I try to tell
if somebody is a quick learner
so I'm keeping that in mind if you're on
the other side and trying to get a job
you know I would say don't be afraid to
list that you've taken a course I mean
be selective right maybe you not might
not want to say like you know hey last
month I took the intro to HTML course
not a big deal but let's say if you took
the advanced react course from wherever
that might seem more impressive like hey
you're trying to learn more right anyway
hopefully that that makes sense that is
decent advice if anyone disagrees please
let me know in the live chat okay
so let's go back let me take a second -
I just I got a bunch of messages while I
was talking I just kept hearing it buzz
I just want to make sure it's nothing
work-related that I need to handle I
think this is not for me I'm a part of a
team that handles like digital marketing
stuff but I'm they're launching
something today it's really important
but I'm just kind of was like more of
consulting on that project so I think
most of the messages are about that but
I don't have any direct responsibility
yeah so that's it so sorry I don't I
don't want to take the focus away from
the stream but I just want to be ready
in case they need help okay let me check
the time all right we're still good I
think we have time for one more Pomodoro
session which I'll start right now and
then I'm gonna keep an eye on the live
chat if I notice there's a lot of
questions in the live chat I might cut
the Pomodoro session short so that I can
get to all the questions but well we'll
see hopefully I am not so focused I
forget about the time all right so let's
go into the events the last thing that
we were talking about was kind of
switching up how we do this and let's
see
yeah let's let's take out this image and
then add in a date yeah I think that
would be better to add in a more
prominent date and not have images for
events okay I do see a few more
questions if you're just joining and
asking a question just hold on after in
about 25 minutes I'm gonna go back and
answer all the questions so just be
patient for a little while longer I'll
definitely get to your questions all
right let me get rid of this give us
some more space yeah so I'm gonna go in
here then and take out these list items
oops not the whole thing
I'm just gonna take out these avatars
which it should be the same yep they're
all the same so I can remove them all at
once and save it now let's see what its
gonna look like area okay so now it
looks like this which is also not ideal
oh you know what I forgot what we were
gonna do I was going to go to the
material design documentation so
material dot iOS material design website
just go to our guidelines and let's see
if they have a list area lists so we
actually have two different lists we
have a grid list as well so let's just
check out the regular list for right now
see these are the lists that actually
you know they do have this circular
image here and as I said earlier it
works really well with with like
portraits right so just somebody's face
and maybe a little bit of their upper
body but with larger you know images
like the type of images you might want
to have with an event see maybe you
don't want somebody's face
if somebody is a speaker giving a talk
yeah that's fine but you know not all
the events are like that
so you know might not be bad to have an
icon if the events fell into certain
categories we could have maybe an icon
for each category
I guess that's an option
all right see you see how we have here
this is what I was thinking that would
work is if we had a title short
description and then some sort of image
but I'm just not so sure that we have
the space for that we could I mean we do
have more padding than we really need
right here that kid could give it us a
little bit more space Michael said is G
fuel time hey I happen to have some G
fuel ready right here let me say if you
don't stake it up after it's been
sitting it's not this is not as good so
just the pro tip for you there if you
want to use G fuel all right Nickey says
the grid list in material design looks
cool all right let's check out the grid
list so I want to spend too much time on
the list so we'll give it just a little
scroll here just to see what else is
here
all right this is maybe more what will
end up with something like this without
the image all right now let's check the
grid list if you haven't checked through
this documentation before I highly
recommend it if you're at all interested
in material design its it's just really
really useful oh okay here's the grid
list yeah I'm not sure
see
if we do this we definitely we can't do
image only we would need to have the
title maybe something more like this but
I I kind of I suspect that my boss will
want more area for more an area for text
you know this just really doesn't give
us that much space and if we did add
more text that would cover you know
pretty much the whole image with text so
hmm yeah I really do like this look
though I want to keep this in mind in
case there's somewhere else on the site
where we could utilize something like
this I think that's nice it it will
require though that we have images you
know I you can really use this if only
some of what you're putting in here has
a good image okay
this list controls okay
ya don't need that actually if we were
to have some sort of control on the list
what I would want to have is like
something where you could quickly add
this to a calendar that would be useful
potentially if we can't work it in here
we could have it so that when you click
it takes you to the event page gives you
more info and then you can add it to
your calendar there but really it saves
users from having to go to another page
if we could put it in here so I think it
should be in there if we can so let's
let's think about this for a second in
terms of how much space we're using when
we're on a screen this small do we want
to keep the cards like fully have the
cards or do we want to change it so that
you know we're completely full full
width and we're still going to have two
separate sections out somehow
I don't know maybe we should take a look
you know soon I'm saying here like let's
say we were in a nap right there's no
cards here these these aren't cards not
I mean this is within a list
Nicki's asking about icons for material
actually let's take a look at the icons
oops
hi Khan's alright so there are a ton of
free material design icons under which
link
alright so let's say I look at the
calendar
okay so date yeah there's nothing in
there those ones aren't really working
oops bad are there's a nice add to
shopping cart there's an add an alert at
a notes yeah but there's not already an
ADD calendar
yes we'd have to think about it
yeah let's see so I mean some apps it's
actually not even consistent because
some Google apps that are using material
design have cards within it so I'm
thinking of you maybe like the news the
newsstand app so if you are material or
I'm sorry an Android phone and you check
out the newsstand app there are there
cards I mean they change they change
this somewhat frequently so it could be
different but like the first set of cars
the briefing is one large card that's
that's basically a list which which kind
of matches up with something that we do
here and actually this format's not bad
for news and events if we switched it up
and use a similar format hmm that's
really interesting
I'm sorry I need to like show you all
this this format
alright so basically there's two
different formats that are using in the
newsstand app for displaying basically
an image some icons and but yeah
actually it's just now some of them have
a title and they have a description it
looks like if there's a large a long
title they don't have the description
yeah so some do some some zone all right
but they have two different formats so
let me try to explain this so basically
at first they do have a card and it does
have padding on the side so they have a
large card like this they have the title
here but then they have the image here
and a few icons actually three icons
underneath one for sharing ones a little
menu icon and the other one is to
bookmark it and then they have a you
know optional description it looks like
under here and then each item is
separated by like a horizontal line here
very light grey horizontal line and then
as you scroll down it switches over and
they have these cards that are full
width but they still have the separation
and this material design style shadow
between them but they are full width in
there more like this where they have the
image up here and then it's I title and
then text and then the the icons for
those cards are down at the bottom here
so actually either one of those formats
will work once again though it's I think
it's just a question of will we have
appropriate images that will work for
something like that and for the events
currently we don't so I don't really
know I don't know if we have the content
to back up that type of design
i misspelled newsstand I did
20:16
all right it's always dangerous just
clicking on the image tab but you never
know it's gonna come up but I just want
to show you all all right this looks
this isn't exactly what I'm saying
this looks like maybe an older version
but somewhat similar yeah actually
that's definitely an older an older
version let's see this looks newer yeah
okay so this is that first section here
where it's one big card this is what I
was thinking might work for us so what
do you all think about something like
this for the events and actually if we
don't have an image this section here
could maybe just have the month in the
day maybe that's maybe that maybe month
and day I don't know if we could fit in
the time in here and it's still have it
look right yeah
I mean we definitely have to abandon
some of what's already there in the list
and kind of redo it which I mean we've
done that before so it'll be a little
bit more work but this this might work I
mean obviously we don't need all these
icons and we don't need this part here
and we don't need the numbers either it
looks like looks like the horizontal
line doesn't actually extend all the way
out to the sides I actually like that I
like that it doesn't extend out all
right let me see I did I said I was
gonna try to keep a watch on the live
chat to see how many questions we have
okay not a ton of questions let's try to
do just a little bit of work here on
this to make it look so I'm not getting
a lot of feedback on on what you all
think about this so I'm gonna move ahead
since there's no strong objections to it
I'm gonna go ahead with something like
this not exactly but it's something like
this okay I'm gonna move this to my
other screen so I can keep an eye on it
this is kind of an advantage I think of
using something like material design is
it so widely used that you can get kind
of inspiration from other places about
how to handle certain content types
so you're not completely on your own so
and I don't I don't mean like copying
other people you know you'll see
whenever we make this we're not it's not
gonna look exactly the same you know but
it definitely helps to be able to look
at something else and say okay I liked
how they did it this way or you know
maybe this will work for what we're
doing and you usually have to adapt it
but it just kind of helps when you're
when you're stuck and you don't really
have an idea for how you want to do
something all right so I'd like to use
as much of what we already have as
possible as long as it doesn't make it
too difficult okay not bad let's switch
over maybe we can switch over that
avatar section to the other side let's
try that first all right let me just
back up here a second let's get rid of
this here and then we'll move it here
right yeah see what it looks like okay
cool easy enough we don't want it to be
a circle right so let's see where where
do we have just want to see where we
actually have the border radius
I guess it's on the container yeah all
right so we'll change the border radius
here and so on our classes avatar which
we set a width and height let's also set
a border border radius of zero we don't
need the quotation mark since it's just
you know a number but this may or may
not work we'll see since it looks like
they define its materiai define each
border radius separately I'm not sure if
we'll override that oh it did work
awesome cool okay so we do have now a
square image just great that's what I
wanted and I think I do think we need
just overall on a smaller screen we need
less padding so may as well do that now
let's figure out where we're putting
that padding in and what component
okay so maybe on that grid let's check
grid item fix is the class so let's
check out our grid item fix okay and we
do have a 16 pixel padding so it looks
like we can grab this and reuse it here
and this is basically like using a media
query but this is comes built-in in a
material UI so it's a little odd doesn't
look like a normal media query let's add
padding
sooo padding-left let's see if we want
to keep the 16 wonder if we want to keep
it this much space in between or not
this ends up being yeah I don't think we
want that much space because we're doing
16 all around then we end up getting 32
pixels between I think I'd feel better
with 16 pixels in between so let's
change that and these on the small
screen has changed it so let's drop this
down padding all around just to 8 pixels
and that should give us what we want
there okay see so now there's only
there's a total of 16 pixels in between
and now we have a much more slim eight
pixels on each side so that gives us a
bit more space so it's still enough that
we can see it's a card and we can
definitely see separation between cards
but yeah I like that let me know if you
don't like that or you have different
suggestion for that but I think that's
that's nice there's no sense in taking
up extra space when you already have a
really small small screen let me check
the time okay that's all I'm gonna do
for now we're almost out of time for
this Pomodoro session and I did notice
some questions so I want to get to the
questions
so let me commit someone you ought to be
able to see these changes so let me
commit this now and let's say it's your
and really I do the biggest change that
I made really was the change that I just
did there and changing the padding of
the card so that's what I'm gonna put on
the commit message the next commit
message will probably be all those
changes that we're making because we
didn't we didn't really do that much we
just changed the position of the picture
within the events card all right so
let's see
[Music]
I will probably get that yeah we're
gonna get that error again warning so I
keep saying it's an error but it's a
warning if it was an error we wouldn't
be able to commit origin okay all right
so now everything should be available on
github the end Rock server is still up
so you can still check it out if you if
you need to let me scroll up and try to
answer as many questions as I can
hopefully I have enough time to get
through all of them
sym Ranji says how is your pixel phone's
performance I've been very happy with my
pixel it's the the pixel excel pixel one
excel and it's been great there are some
things that that are weird and but I'm
not sure if it's a pixel problem or if
it's a problem with that particular app
so I've had trouble with Instagram just
freezing up on me and crashing I've had
trouble with only certain things and
Facebook not working and just the
loading wheel keep spinning
but like it's I don't know
is that a pixel thing is that you know
because of the app I'm not sure but
overall I've I've been happy with with
the pixel
all right so Shri Ganesh says I'm
learning angular will it be difficult to
switch to react later I'm I don't really
know from experience because I I did
very little with angular before I
started learning react but I assume that
someone who is capable of learning
angular is certainly capable of learning
reacts so there may be certain concepts
that will be more difficult if you're
used to angular and this is just my
guess I'm not a hundred percent sure but
but if you're intelligent enough and you
know able to learn enough to do one
framework to switch to a different
library like reacts shouldn't be a big
problem so I wouldn't worry too much
about it but like anything it's just
going to take practice gonna take effort
in time
Evos has just joined in and I was
wondering how the Pomodoro timer helps
you besides not going too long one of
the unexpected helps of using Pomodoro
timer to break up my work is that I do
my 25-minute session and then I take my
break in that break time sometimes so I
try not to think about what I'm doing so
sometimes I'll think about something
else and it just puts my work in
perspective and it stops me from
spending too much time on one task that
maybe isn't that important so I don't
know if this has happened to any of you
but occasionally I'll get stuck on some
problem and I'll keep working at it and
working at it for hours trying to fix
this problem but in reality the problem
isn't that important and I could just do
like a workaround or just remove that
feature or do something different and it
would have saved a lot of time and in
the big picture it probably would have
been better just to do it that way so
that five minute break really allows me
to recognize when I'm in a situation
like that a lot faster
than I normally would and just kind of
switch things up so to me that's been a
big benefit you know other than the
obvious time management benefits that
you get from you know the Pomodoro
Technique so anyway I should really do a
video on on Pomodoro at some point on my
channel so it's not are already on my
list maybe I'll add it Gerardo says do
you think it's worth fixing github
commits aha
for a side project for myself I never
bother fixing github commits
occasionally I do to me I want to say it
depends on who's going to be looking at
those commits and what it's for really
so I don't I don't have a rule that
covers everything hmm
so I but yeah so it just it kind of
depends and it depends on how much I
messed up the commit so sorry I can't
give you like a rule that would work but
if the commits really messed up then
yeah maybe you know you laugh and fix it
but in general as long as the commit is
still readable it still makes sense if
it's just a small error I'll usually
just leave it I mean it would depend
like if I was you know committing
something to a repo that had pretty
strict rules about it obviously I would
I would want to fix it
Gerardo says I have two accounts work in
home and my work ones are not reflected
as being mine I have to patch the entire
repos I'm afraid I might end up ruining
everything
yeah
I'm not sure how to handle a I don't
know anybody else have any advice but
I'm sorry drawer - I'm trying to think
I'm also I'm trying to get all the
questions in - and I have just a few
more minutes to do that so if I had more
time again think about it a bit more
yeah I mean you definitely want to try
to get credit for what you're doing
let's see let me look at some of the
other questions the five-time I'll come
back to that as well
in s how long have you been coding for
about five years I'd learned coding some
coding stuff a lot you know longer
I learned it a lot farther back than
five years I started coding in in high
school and like the early 2000s early to
mid-2000s and but I didn't do a lot with
it
but I've been kind of more seriously
coding for about the past five years
Aniki says I really like that text the
left image to the right the text is
what's actually important the image is
there for extra flavor oh that's a good
way to put it I you know what I like
that now that you say it it makes
perfect sense
I you know I'm sure like I picked up on
you know like I picked up on hey I like
this but it didn't like come to me that
that's why I like it but now that you
say it like that that's exactly right
the emphasis is on the right part of the
content see Mert says why why the free
code camp always put emphasis on the
front end for this stream in particular
I mean I'm a front-end developer
although I do some back-end stuff you
know from time to time so that's why I
emphasize front-end stuff because that's
most of what I do free code camp in
general I don't I don't know do they
emphasize front anymore I'd have to go
back and check I mean I know their
challenges certainly they have
challenges for back-end in their YouTube
videos it might be the case that friend
gets emphasized more but I guess I just
never really thought about it
so I don't know that as far as you know
I'm concerned I don't there's no effort
on my part to emphasize front or back
end I just do what I have to do for work
and I try to stream as much as I can of
course both are very important for for
web development let's see all right so I
am gonna have to go here in just a
minute or two Gerardo I guess I still
don't have a great answer for your
situation my thing is you know is there
any way if you say you have two accounts
your work account on your home account
I'm assuming these are github accounts
right is there any way I mean does your
work account have your name on it
associated with it if so then you would
be getting credit for your projects on
your work account right is there any way
you know when you want to let people
know what you've worked on that you
could have both of your accounts listed
I mean obviously it's not ideal but at
least you would have the benefit of
getting credit for what you're doing
without having to change anything or
potentially mess up you know any repos
so I don't know if that's an option for
you but maybe I don't know you know
maybe that could work
Mert Mert says that's what I feel this
is a follow-up to the front-end emphasis
question but it says that's what if you
want to follow the instruction on the
site thanks for answering my question oh
yeah no problem yeah I mean sorry I
couldn't answer it you know more fully I
really don't have anything to do with
the creating of the curriculum in all
the challenges
so so I can't answer for sure what the
thinking was before that for for that
part of it I mean there are the
curriculum is guess like the next
version of it is coming out soon so
maybe things might be different then I'm
not sure but you might want to check it
out when the new version comes out as
well and see if there's more balance
between front end and back end all right
so my my calendar is reminding me that I
need to leave in one minute okay now
let's reminding me that I lead need to
leave now so thank you all so much for
watching and thanks for all your help
and all your questions and I should be
back I'll probably be back tomorrow I'm
gonna start having a lot more meetings
than normal this week and then next week
so the times that I stream might be a
little off I may not be able to stream
every day but I'll do my best to fit
them in and so until next time have a
wonderful day